Okay. So here's how I got to you. Okay. I have a,
a former producer and I now a good friend, Pat Walters. Oh yeah. You know pat?
Yes. We corresponded. And then he came to see me speak in San Francisco. Yes.
And it was based on something he saw you talk about,
which is why I'm now contacting you. Interesting. Okay. So, Hey,
I'm Jen [inaudible]. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radiolab and today a story about a set of pictures. Pictures. Yeah.
And a,
a set of questions about those pictures regarding who gets to see the pictures
and who gets to decide who gets to see the pictures.
Did we get to see the pictures? Well, that's kind of the question.
So I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna answer that yet. Um,
but I w I should say that there are some moments in this story that get a
little, what's the word? Heavy. Heavy. Yeah.
So be forewarned, but we'll start with the picture taker.
My name is Lindsay Adario and I'm a photojournalist.
She's been covering war for the last 15 years. I've done military and beds,
infantry units, patrolling, going in house to house searches.
She's worked in well everywhere. Sudan, Libya, Lebanon, Pakistan,
a million places. She's been kidnapped twice. She's won a Pulitzer, a MacArthur,
and she's been called one of the most influential photographers of the past 25
years. In any case, this particular story, can you set it up a little bit?
Sure. Uh,
so in December of 2009,
she was taking pictures for Time magazine. She was in Afghanistan,
Gazmere district, Helmand province,
stationed at a base in the middle of the desert.
I was embedded with the metabolic team and their role is to go in and pick up
injured troops out of, uh, the theater of war.
This is a small team of basically helicopter pilots, medics, doctors.
Basically whenever there's an injured soldier,
these teams are called whichever team is closest to the injured.
We're talking like helicopter dropping into, oh yeah. I mean, this is fast,
this.
So Lindsay had been embedded with this team for a couple of days and not much
what's happening?
So you're just sitting around reading magazines and then rereading the same
magazines and one night really late.
But I think I was lying in bed and I was totally like if I wasn't asleep,
I was on the verge of sleep. When they, someone ran was like
there was an alpha.
Alpha is like Alpha means the most gravely wounded,
like you have seconds to get there. I mean it's life or death.
So she grabs two cameras, her helmet and body armor runs out to the Black Hawk.
I strap myself in and we take off.
And I think it was about a two minute flight, which is so fast.
And I remember I was shooting the fields as we flew in because I was trying to
focus and see what I can see.
Luckily they had lent me a set of night vision goggles, which was really nice.
The military,
cause you can't see anything without them in the middle of the night because
they are using night vision. So they don't ever turn on the light.
So if you were to look through the camera directly, you would see nothing.
Just blackness, nothing. So what you do for photographers,
you put the night vision goggles in front
of the Camera Lens, so it looks green, it's fluorescent green.
Does that mean that the picture you get is green? Yes.
So they fly for two minutes through the pitch black land, the helicopter.
She has no idea where and everything is happening extremely fast.
I'm trying to focus as I'm looking out the helicopter door and suddenly in my
view finder, I see
[inaudible]
a man sort of wrapped. I think he was wrapped in a blanket and he's a,
he gets put right in front of me on the floor of that, of the Black Hawk.
The first thing I thought is I think he's already dead.
He seemed completely unresponsive and he seemed so young.
I just remember looking at his face and thinking, God,
what are we doing here? Within seconds there airborne again,
flying back to the field hospital,
Lindsey takes pictures on that brief flight back,
grainy fluorescent green images of the medics tending to the soldier,
checking his vitals. We land at the field office.
Well,
they rushed him on a stretcher into the hospital tent and the whole team of
medics, navy nurses, the anesthesiologist, everyone is there.
They carry him inside and put him immediately on the table. Uh,
cut his clothes off, they're cutting his pants off, um,
open up his shirt and the room starts filling up with everyone because everyone
has heard that there's an alpha. And so troops come in from across the base,
sort of in support. She says within minutes,
the room went from just a handful of people, five, six to a dozen, 20,
and it's a, you can hear a pin drop. I mean,
the room is silent except for the doctors, you know,
they're trying to resuscitate him.
He had lost I think eight or nine pints of blood. They're bringing in blood,
they're bringing in all sorts of things. And um,
I you shooting this whole time? Well, yeah, of course. You know,
I'm basically trying to be invisible because it's so sensitive to be a
photographer in that situation. What I do, I don't shoot like Bang My,
my [inaudible], you know,
I shoot one frame and then I put my camera down and I shoot another frame
because you can hear the click of the shutter and it is like exponentially
louder than normal in a situation like that. What did you get? Did anyone look,
give you a look of like, oh back off or anything like that?
At one point I was shooting for probably, I don't know,
five or six minutes maybe.
And an officer walked over to me and he said, hey,
stop photographing and yeah,
and I put the camera down and I looked at him and I said, I have permission.
She had worked all that out beforehand.
That's part of the conditions of her in bed. We had had all these conversations,
you know, what happens in the case of this, what is my access, what can I do?
But at this point she says, ah,
the room was full of people from across the base who didn't know any of that,
didn't know who she was, that she had permission.
And so she was sort of at this fork in the road.
There were those like that officer who clearly felt put the camera down. Stop.
Obviously this is not the time to argue or to be disrespectful.
So I didn't say anything else. I put the camera down.
But she says the moment she did that several other troops said no,
let her shoot. This has to be documented. Oh that's interesting.
So you have one guy who says, you can't take a picture of this. Right.
Almost like anything but this. Right. And another guy's like, no,
this especially right. Right. First of all,
the guy who said no was being protective. It made perfect sense for me,
but I think the guys who who stood up and said this has to be documented.
I think at some point everyone realized like, look,
this war is not going away.
We are losing so many lives and limbs and and no one is seeing it.
[inaudible]
and keep in mind,
this is 2009 this is just the tail end of a 18 year ban where the news media
couldn't even photograph military coffins. In any case,
the officer let it go.
Lindsay continued to take pictures for about another 20 minutes.
She took pictures of the doctors cutting open the boy's chest,
massaging his heart. At some point I remember someone,
one of the doctors looked up and said,
does anyone else have any suggestions basically for how to save him?
And everyone said no. And they sort of disconnected.
The Emini died.
People were looking down and then they were looking at each other and someone
went to go get a flag and American flag to drape over his body.
And I continued photographing and there was a moment where, uh,
the whole room was silent and people stood around his body draped with a flag
and said a prayer.
That to me is one of the most powerful images that came out of this whole
series.
There's this old idea in photography called the decisive moment that the world
is filled with these far off realities.
But every so often a photograph can capture a moment. The boom takes you there.
This is one of those photos in the picture.
You see all these men and women standing in kind of a loose semicircle.
Some of them still have their, a blue surgical gloves on.
They look totally spent.
They're all looking in different directions and they all look like they're not
even there. Like they're totally lost in their own thoughts.
Their attention is clearly inwards. Yeah.
I'm sure all those troops were like, God, that could've been me.
Why couldn't we save him? What are we doing here in Afghanistan?
Is this war wars yet?
And to read the expressions on their faces like it's even,
you can be at war as a journalist,
but never actually get to the heart of the war because we don't have access or
people don't open up. And I felt like I really had reached, oh,
of like the crux of the war. Interesting. It was war.
You'd seen an essence of something. Yeah, but then came a problem.
Any photos that she had taken that included that soldiers face or any other
identifying marks like tattoos.
And he did have tattoos according to the rules of her bed.
She couldn't use those photos without the soldiers permission. Right.
And you never got to speak to him. No. So was it days later,
weeks later, months later, where you began to ask yourself, can I, he knew,
I taught. It was minutes later, it's,
the military does not let a journalist cover something like this without coming
directly to that person.
And so literally like I followed the young man's body out to the morgue and they
had to walk him outside. And I remember that it was,
the moon was so bright that night and I was shooting with the moonlight as he
was being carried outside. And then, uh,
I went back to the tent where I was staying and within minutes of the Military
Pao, the Marines, uh, public affairs officers came and said, uh, you know,
you can't send those images out without permission from the next of kin.
That's the rule for soldiers unconscious and then dies before giving permission.
I have to then go to the next of kin. And I said, of course I understand.
You know, I'm not doing anything with those photos in that moment.
I signed this piece of paper. I, when I give my word, I keep that word,
you know. But then the other side of me was like, fuck, you know, in Vietnam,
no one was signing pieces of paper and in Vietnam, no one had to, to,
to go to the next akin before they publish anything.
And that's why the American public,
I think rose up against the war in Vietnam because they saw the most graphic
devastating images that were uncensored.
So then what do you do in that situ circumstance? I mean,
I imagine you go to the next of kin, right? Well,
you're not allowed as a journalist to reach out to the next of kin.
They asked me, are you interested in being contacted by the next of kin?
If they're willing to speak to you. Oh, so you can't even actually call? No,
they will not give you the information. But I said, um, you know,
of course I would like to be contacted by the next of Canon,
please pass my information on. And I was sort of just waiting.
I mean at this point were you thinking the pictures would ever see the light of
day? I had no idea. And um,
few days later, maybe less than a week or in bed was over,
she was flying to JFK on our way to meet her family for Christmas and I had
voicemails on my telephone
[inaudible]
and I listened and it was his father?
No,
and he left me a voicemail and he said,
I understand you were with my son when he died and I would like to talk to you
and this is my phone number.
I sort of choked up just listening to his voice,
anticipating how difficult that phone call would be,
that phone call when all the fallout is coming up.
[inaudible]
my name is Luciana Masako and I'm calling from my office in Houston, Texas.
Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology. In the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
okay.
Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by progressive progressive offers you tons of ways to save
on insurance, starting with building and savings,
like discounts for being a safe driver.
You can also save for getting a quote online and when you bundle home and auto,
you can even save more. In fact,
customers who switched to progressive can save an average of $668 a year on car
insurance. Start a quote online and start saving today. Visit progressive.com
Radiolab is supported by swell, investing, and impact investing platform.
What have you got?
Invest in our planet while also investing in your financial future?
Think about that. Our resources are diminishing. Our population is growing.
Companies solving today's biggest challenges will be tomorrow's leaders.
Swell helps you invest in high growth companies working towards clean water.
When you will able energy and green technology.
It's a market opportunity you can feel good about.
Get a $50 bonus when you open your account at swell,
investing.com/radiolab
hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab. So Lindsey Addario,
the photographer has these photos, uh, these intense photos of a soldier dying,
but you can't use them without getting permission from the next of kin. Right.
Few days later I had voicemails on my telephone and I listened and it was his
father. His father's name is Todd Taylor. Son's name was Jonathan Taylor,
my son. And just to jump ahead for a second,
as we were talking about the phone call and the fallout from that phone call,
I had all of these questions about what Todd Taylor was thinking and questions
about his son, things that Lindsay couldn't possibly the answer.
So at a certain point in the universe, you just told me, I don't know. I mean,
you could maybe interview on, do you think he would? I mean, is that, is that,
is there any gray ambition of me talking to him? Well,
I'd be happy to give you some. Yeah. Gee, I'd love to talk to you. I mean,
you can try.
Lindsey put us in touch and I'll just tell you about the visit for a second.
Todd Taylor was willing to talk. He had two conditions.
One was like, if I'm gonna do this story about these photos of his son,
I should at least get to know his son a little bit.
And the second was that I come down to Florida to meet him and his family
personally. The destination is on your left.
Hey,
did you have a Taylor family live in a section of Jacksonville?
It's near a naval base, so there are a lot of military families there.
Come on in and read all the dog. Todd is x e x navy himself.
He introduced me to his three giant boxers.
They sort of introduced themselves. And then my daughter,
my youngest dad met his daughters. I am Lauren Taylor.
I am 16 going on 17 Oh oh it's about to add that.
My name is McKinsey Taylor. I'm Jonathan Zither sister and I'm 20 years old.
The little voice you here in the background as Easton, he's about to Esther,
one of the babies. She watches. Hey handsome McKinsey works as a nanny.
My Name's Paige Larson and Jonathan stepsister.
And I'm 21 my name is sue Taylor and I'm, I'm Jonathan Step-mom.
And then of course
I'm Todd Taylor. I'm Jonathan's Dad. Um,
we're here in my house in Jacksonville,
Florida and today is Jonathan's birthday. It's
April 8th, 2015 so he would've been held today 28 years old today,
when I got there, they pulled out photo albums of Jonathan.
We all sat at the kitchen table and looked at pictures,
no pictures of them as a baby. So that was very young toddler.
This was on the Disney cruise. I took him on adolescent Kennedy Space Center,
teenager, see him running track. He like cross country going to prom.
That was Jonathan's girlfriend.
You think you notice immediately in all the pictures and big blue eyes,
he's got these eyes that are not just blue. They're really blue.
Like if you boosted the brightness and Photoshop or something. Yeah. This,
I forgot. I think we're on vacation here,
but the other thing you notice is facial expressions are really [inaudible] a
big class clown. Lot of goofy faces.
Very good. Big goofball. Goofball. Yeah,
definitely knew how to make anybody laugh
full of energy. Always in the stuff. He kept the boys away too.
Definitely most definitely made sure if I had boyfriends you'd call them just to
see what grades they had. Really. He would check on their grades. Yeah.
Kind of give him a little interview. I do remember he was very protective.
If I had a crush, he'd be like, oh no, you're not going to have a crush. No,
no boys. There was one time before he left for Afghanistan,
like I really sick with a fever and I remember him holding my hand just so he
can make sure that I was OK and, and took care of me.
They told me story after story about how he doted on his sisters,
how we love to read and it to become a history teacher.
After his four years in the marines and inevitably the conversation turned to
the day that they found out he died December 1st,
2009 they get a call from Jonathan's mom. I'm saying set classic scene.
Oh my God.
There were two marines at the door and we just kind of like left everything to
Todd. The girls jumped in the car race over. They all wanted to get out.
We're like, no, cause we didn't really know what was gonna happen.
So we made all the girls stay in the car and I remember walking in the door and
everyone just had this look on their face like the world had just ended.
And um,
I remember asking what happened.
My mom had told me he was gone.
[inaudible] the first thing I did was run to his room because everything was the
same before he had left.
I remember opening his closet and I'm grabbing one of his shirts and just
holding onto it because it still had it sent on it.
That night was really hard.
One thing that had never occurred to me, totally caught me off guard.
And in thinking about those pictures is that when those marines came to the door
and told them the news, well,
they didn't actually give much news.
This right here with this one. This is what was red.
Todd actually read me the circumstances of death statement.
Hostile action,
result of multiple traumatic injuries received as a member of a dismounted
patrol that was struck by an id while conducting combat operations in the
Hellman province. That was it on patrol night patrol,
that's all I had. He didn't know anything. That's it.
Jonathan's unit was still in Afghanistan so he couldn't talk to anyone.
He had no clue what happened to his son.
So when that casualty assistance officer told him actually there was a
photographer in the room with your son, when he died
automatically I was like, I wanted to want to call her.
Earlier in my conversation with Lindsey, I'd asked her,
what do you remember that the call?
So the call, um,
I went to my mother's house in Connecticut and I asked my mother to be left
alone, which in a big Italian American family means
she sort of looked at me like what? And I,
I went up into the guest bedroom and I called him and he picked up,
I think he thanked me for calling him. I don't remember exactly what we said,
but I said, you know,
I was with your son when he died and I will give you as much or as little
information as you want. And he said, I want to know
everything because I wasn't there. I was here. He said,
I want to know every single thing I want to be with my son just to lose him and
not be there for him. That was hard, really hard.
And I felt sort of very awkward because I felt like, well, you know,
why was I privy to this moment? Um, and he is, the father could not be privy.
The most important question to me was did he suffer and do you think,
did he suffer? I said, no. She told me, Ms. Taylor, I don't,
I don't think you separate. I think he was in shock. I told him everything,
how much blood his son lost. How long did they try to save him?
And at some point I said, look, I have these pictures.
I have all of these pictures.
I shot everything and I need your permission to publish the ones that show his
face. Oh yeah. She asked me a permission and
he was quiet.
I said, um, I told her yes but, but
he said, Aye. Aye Can I see them?
And I wanted to see him first before I give permission.
I want to see every photo. And I said, you know,
I'm not sure you want to see these photos cause they're graphic,
but he wanted to see the outtake. He wanted to see every photo, all of them.
Yep. Of course we were on the phone.
I couldn't show them pictures and legally I needed permission from Time magazine
to show him anything because you know as a journalist you can't show anything to
anyone until it's published.
You don't show people pictures of journalism before you publish them.
This is one of those cardinal rules that's drilled into.
Every journalist said if you show a subject,
the raw stuff before it's out there,
you kind of given up the only independence you've got.
That's why she says ordinarily I would never ever,
ever show just to play it out for a second if he to be cynical about it.
If you show him the pictures,
he might take away permission that he might've otherwise give you. Exactly.
Exactly. You can say as a publication, no, I won't show those pictures before.
You have to just say yes or no.
What do you give your permission like in a way if you get down to it,
I feel like one of the fundamental layers here is just like a question of who's
right when it comes to that information is more important.
I could hear an argument that's has the battle is important.
It was authorized by public figures.
It is carrying America's message into the world and shouldn't Americans see what
goes on? Yeah, but I could hear an argument that says,
shouldn't a dad be able to protect who sees his son in that situation? Yeah.
In any case, Lindsey called her editors at time.
They had a series of conversations that went all the way up to the editor of
time.
We had a very intense conversation and we collectively made a decision to show
him the photos to say that decision was unusual from their perspective would be
severely understating it.
When I first got these, um, from FedEx,
I knew they were coming and I was actually
scared to look at them and I saw my son there
and I just kept looking and looking.
You can see these were the in the metabolic when they got him on.
You see the Night Vision Lens? There's Jonathan's body. Hi, it's jazz.
There's a space. There's the oxygen
still as watch on stone. See his eyes closed there. That was, yeah,
so many hands in the work and you can see they're doing CPR there
now.
Here you see right leg is really mangled and broken.
That's really why I lost so much blood. It was this. All right in here.
Some of these pictures are there. Some of them that are really hard to see.
Yeah,
but even though they show that I've messed up war,
I've got a piece of Jonathan. This is my treasure.
I'll show you one of the pictures that to me it's,
it always stands out. You brought up the picture of the prayer.
All those people standing in a semicircle with far away eyes run here.
You just see a little different in their faces here. I mean
it meant something. He was somebody.
Yeah. It wasn't just a number.
Dad said he wanted people to see this picture and the others to convey what's
happening over there. This is going on every day. And he says for him,
it's not a political thing.
You can feel however you want to feel about the wars we're in.
For him it's about people seeing what is actually happening. I mean,
I wanted to let people see in the sacrifices that these boys do it too.
Todd and his family over a month to decide what to do about those pictures,
whether it grant time, permission to run the photos or not.
He says ultimately he called Jonathan's mother over
her and her husband and um, my wife and I,
we all discussed it and ultimately he said no,
and it was a lot of back and forth. He said no to showing any pictures at all.
Well, he can't say no to any pictures because, oh,
because there's pictures without the face. Yeah, exactly.
He said no to any pictures with the face or identifying marks.
We decided really that, uh, we didn't want these pictures to get out, um,
for fear that his sisters, somehow they'd get back to them.
And that was the big thing.
I didn't want them to be able to see this yet as their dad.
I want to protect them from seeing certain things. And so
we decided not to do it.
Time had planned to run a whole photo spread on the Medevac team trying to save
Jonathan Taylor's life. But since they now couldn't use most of those photos,
they had to make the photo spread more general. What had been the,
basically the death of a soldier ultimately became a photo essay on the Mat of
act team.
And those pictures were maybe two pictures or three pictures in that spread.
But they were not the focus prayer photo is in the news spread because in that
photo you can't see his body cause it's covered with a flag.
There are no identifying marks but somehow in that context it's,
it's not got the same impact weirdly because you're seeing the after without the
before. Exactly. And you know,
let's see here.
Todd showed me the original photo spread cause they had sent that to him.
You know, again, super unusual. So this is the, um,
this is the feature they wanted to do. Yeah. Let me see.
The pictures are so much more clearer. This is kind of the layout.
It's going to be to cock 29
minutes, crapping it out minute by minute. This whole process,
see there you see all the before pictures that lead up to the prayer and what it
seemed to me, it's like if you don't see all that stuff, the the,
the wounds and the blood and the tenderness as they tried to come from him and
then the emptiness they feel when they couldn't save him.
Like if you don't see all that,
you're not really standing with them in that prayer at the end.
You're still seeing them across the space. That's interesting.
In the original spread, you are there in that room and they did a,
they did a great job. You know,
it's really powerful and I couldn't help but think that like maybe this would
have created that conversation that Lindsay talked about just a tiny bit and
like how weird that I'm one of the only people to see it
and to know that like I,
the only reason I can describe it to you is because I'm on the radio, you know,
I will always feel like journalistically
we, we sacrifice, you know,
we did not tell the story as powerfully as we could have,
but we had integrity and I feel like we treated everyone with respect and we
kept our word Lindsey and Todd now stay in touch over email once or twice a
year. And in terms of keeping your word,
Todd has made a deal with his daughters that they can see the pictures when they
turn 21 but interestingly, um,
the three of them don't agree as to whether they want to Paige and McKinsey who
are about to turn 21 say they don't want to see the pictures.
I just can't handle it. Do you feel to feel sad? I think for me,
I just don't want to see them in pain, you know, that's Mackenzie. So on the CA,
cause I'd rather just remember him in one piece, how he was.
I'm just too sensitive. That's Paige. Now. Lauren, the youngest for me,
she says she needs to see those pictures because I want to know what he went
through.
And I like constantly knowing things and I don't like things being kept from me
and I just wanna I guess I just want a visual. She says she knows he's gone,
but she's still somehow needs proof. Not that it happened,
she knows it happened, but so it feels real.
[inaudible]
okay. So, um, big thanks to Pat Walters. Um, cure Pollock,
the Taylor family and of course Lindsay Adario, she has a book out now called,
it's what I do,
which is sort of a memoir about her war photography and how it's changed her
life. And uh, that book is filled with her photography.
Anything like the ones we didn't see. Oh,
there's some amazing pictures in there, but nothing like, like these ones.
So yeah, that's it. I'm Jana. Boom. Ron, I remember crow,
which thanks for listening.